if you want to learn more about politics
economics and society
here are five news sources for you
part 1 No. 1
Deutschevale
DW are a German news agency who are particularly good at covering Geo politics
reporting is very neutral
they do brilliant documentaries on YouTube
and everything they do is available in English
No. 2 Reuters
Reuters are arguably the most respectable news association in the world
they supply the majority of western
news outlets with the news that they present you
So for example
when you watch the BBC
the news that you're watching
they will have bought from Reuters journalists before
whole reason Reuters have so much respect
is because of the neutrality of their reporting
they are particularly good at reporting on economics and financial matters
Bloomberg kind of similar too
but bear in mind with both of these
you get a limit as the amount of free articles you can read from them
No.3 TLDR
TLDR are a younger company most of their presenters are young adults
and they're particularly good at covering Geo politics
they do have a UK specific channel
but they also have a global and a European one
they do fantastic 10 minute summaries of contemporary problems
and the majority of what they cover is neutral
at times as a little bit of a left of centre bias
that's just my opinion though
I've seen their application forms
and they clearly make an effort to keep it neutral
No.4 politics home
politics home is particularly good for UK politics
it includes the opinions of people from all sides of the spectrum
and for bias checking
its ranks very neutral
And no.5 the economist
unsurprisingly
the economist is particularly good for economics and financial news
sometimes its article seems slightly more left of centre
sometimes they seem slightly more right of centre
overall I would say it's a pretty central news source
bear in mind that you have to pay for it after a limited amount of free articles
in Part 2 I'm gonna give you a mix of sources that are more biased
but it's important to remember to read left and right media
so that you can see what's being said
drop a follow if you wanna see that